Ross Tucker former NFL lineman and a
host of the Ross Tucker podcast joining
us on the program should we be having
free agency in the NFL right now Ross
you know what Dan I'm okay with it
either way I know a lot of people have
really strong opinions on it on the one
hand I get it that we're in a national
crisis and you could argue that the NFL
should take the lead and setting an
example to people that everybody that
can hit the pause button in life right
now should hit the pause button and with
everything social distancing and
everything that everyone's trying to do
maybe the NFL would set an example in
that regard I guess if you're the NFL
though you could spin it the other way
which is with everyone having to stay at
home for the most part and with social
distancing we're going to be there a
diversion all it is is agents talking to
team executives on the phone from home
about how much money their guys going to
be so well everybody has to stay home
while we're all in this together the NFL
will be our diversion and our topic to
talk about I see both arguments I think
the big issue or the big point I would
make in favor of people that say keeping
it now is I don't think it's gonna get
better than anytime soon I mean bet
everything I've read two weeks from now
would be worse four weeks from now it'll
still be worse so it might be better to
do it now as opposed to two months from
now yeah because once you postpone it
you can UNPO spun it and I like I don't
have a problem and you know some people
talked about the sensitivity of where we
are as a country and these guys are
gonna be signing these
multimillion-dollar contracts I Ryan
Tannehill did not offend me one bit
noting that he signed this deal with
this day with the Titans I and if Brady
signs or Reese on I'm not going to be
bothered by it by saying how insensitive
that he's gonna make that money at some
point so who cares if he's making it now
or he makes it you know in two weeks
from now yeah I mean Dan litter
yesterday there were all kinds of guys
that signed Devin McCourty in New
England Costanzo back with the Colts for
33 million over two years Bradley Roby
with the Texans there was a big trade
with the Jags and the Ravens with coleus
Campbell first of all I didn't hear a
single person say how insensitive that
these guys are getting these contracts
right now secondly they were able to do
all those deals and I know that there
are some people say well they need to
take physicals etc and you know
potentially they could then void the
deal later on and say that they didn't
pass the physical they do that now
sometimes I mean they do that now when
they are able to get the guy for a
physical two or three days later after
this tampering period I mean they're not
even allowed to have the guy visit till
Wednesday anyway meanwhile in exactly
two hours there will be Jack Buckland or
somebody will there'll be a report that
he's agreed to terms of the team ten
minutes into the tampering period and
he's not allowed to even get a physical
till after Wednesday at 4:00 p.m. anyway
so they already if they want to have
buyer's remorse they can already fail
the guy on the physical if they want to
I don't think it's as big a deal as
other people are making it I really
don't all right the Titans bring back
Ryan Tannehill now you got to decide
what you do with Derek Henry and Jack
Conklin what would you do so first of
all I would have franchise tags Ryan
Tannehill you know he had a really good
half of the year but then they just
fully committed to him 91 million
dollars for three years like that is
happening
Tannehill is gonna be there he's getting
the 91 million it's 62 million in the
first two but three days in the next
year's league year the 29 million for
2022 becomes fully guaranteed but he's
couldn't be their quarterback 91 million
for three years I would have franchise
tagged him and made him do it again I
would have taken my chance to with Derek
Henry on the market who's the team on
there that's going to give Derek Henry a
ton of money on a long-term deal there's
literally Dan a graveyard
runningbacks david johnson and girly and
Devonta Freeman just got cut and every
running back that's gotten a big deal
their team has ended up regretting it I
don't need to be very much of a market
for Derrick Henry I would have tagged
Tannehill I would have let Henry test
the market and believe and I'd still be
the one that would be willing all from
the most money and I try to keep Conklin
although Conklin is gonna get a lot of
money and he's been inconsistent and a
little bit injury prone so someone's
gonna make him the highest-paid tackle
in the NFL I'd be willing to let him go
elsewhere yeah my philosophy is if I'm
drafting you in the first round I'm
gonna use you up for five years if your
running back and then I'm gonna let you
go and you know that's what I would have
done with the Zeki Oh Elia to find the
Cowboys I think that offensive line is
so good that I can put a quality running
back in there who was gonna at least
give me a thousand if not you know 1,200
1,300 yards and I don't think Zeek
Elliot is the running back that he once
was and you know what Dan I'm glad you
said that because if you go back to the
end of the year and in particular two
playoff games where Derek Henry got so
much love and so much attention and he
deserves the credit
he had some terrific runs but go back
and watch how many of those runs against
the Patriots and Ravens that Derek Henry
got three or four yards before he was
touched in particular the left side of
the line
Taylor LaVon and Roger Saffold they were
killing dudes so you have a guy that's
250 pounds runs a for 340 get a seven
yard run II yeah he's gonna get some
yards I promise you he's gonna get some
yards the Titans offensive line was
awesome I think that they did this the
wrong way I would have tagged Tannehill
made him prove it and I would have tried
it done to deal with Derek Henry I just
don't see another NFL team saying you
know what let's give Derek Henry what
dick Elliot just got exactly nobody was
gonna do that he's rocks Ross Tucker
former NFL player former Patriot legend
and host of the Ross Tucker podcast what
do you think the Patriots game plan is
well they brought back McCourty and
Slater
there's not as much room for them now in
terms of money III think that the fact
that very little news is trickling out
about Brady right now is interesting the
Titans are out the Niners are out now I
had Albert Brewer on my podcast this
morning
he said the Chargers are still in so I
know Chris Sims had said that it was
down to the Bucs or the Patriots Albert
sort of disputed that on my podcast this
morning I still think he probably goes
back to New England and that that's what
belcheck once but it does seem weird to
me that there isn't more conversation
there I mean everybody keeps talking
about this sit-down meeting that they
need to have that they haven't had yet
well where's that going to take place
now when is that going to take place now
and I think deep down Brady would like
to go back but if he once again feels a
little bit underappreciated and
disrespected it's gonna be hard then you
know the Chargers in the Bucs are gonna
give Brady offer him whatever he wants
money-wise for both business and
football reasons they both have much
more talented skilled people I think he
still things to get the best chance to
win in New England I think he likes
McDaniels and the familiarity there but
at some point if you've got two people
that are really giving you everything
you want and the other ones still kind
of lukewarm I you know he might just say
you know what I'm sick of it I'm done
with it I'm rolling all the other two
teams that's making it seem like they
actually really want me as opposed to me
having to kind of grovel to Bella check
yet again well you know that he's gonna
get that feeling I mean I can't imagine
if he I think he's going back but I
thought that all along but it's not like
Bella checks gonna all of a sudden go
can't think you know it's so great to
see you Tom I get emotional there it's a
business that you know but for a player
it's personal for management its
business now for Robert Kraft he's got
to run a business and it's gonna be
personal with Tom but I think that he
understands you know how much do I want
to load up and keep Tom here just for
memories sake you know it's like the
Lakers with Kobe where they spent that
kind of money those last two years
because they wanted him to retire as a
Laker and it was one reason for people
to go out and see the team they weren't
winning the Patriots expect to win
that's why if he wants to have another
chance at another championship then he
might take less money less respect but a
better opportunity to win yeah you know
what Dan I think we are going to have an
unprecedented amount of leaked
information if Brady goes somewhere else
what do you mean because the stakes well
I just mean the PR battle if he signs
somewhere else is going to be intense
because the Patriots in Boston are not
going to want their fans to think that
it was them that moved on I don't think
Brady you know as no publicly they'll be
classy about it I had a great 20 years
but you know it's a different time in my
life but then you'll start to have the
leaks where it'll be well the Patriots
only offered Brady you know the Patriots
so leak that they offer them a two-year
deal then it'll come out that well it
was only 15 million a year there's just
too much at stake too many legacies on
the line for how this thing ends but I
I'm almost intrigued to see him go
somewhere else just to see what's a PR
battle behind the scenes end up being do
you think that we should hold the draft
oh I have an idea for this look
especially if they push back to lead
year Dan you're gonna love this I'm
going to tweet this soon this is what we
all need they should start the draft if
they're gonna start free agency now
start the draft like in two weeks and we
do a different first-round pick every
day because they're not gonna actually
have a draft like they're not gonna have
a draft for 600,000 fans it's just gonna
be like a made-for-tv conference call
event but let's say we start the draft
April first and the Bengals have the
first pick April second will be the
Redskins day so that Dan Patrick show
the Ross Tucker podcast all of us all
day we'll just talk about who they gonna
take are they gonna trade what are they
gonna do and then that night it because
there's literally nothing else
sports-wise going on if the NFL was
smart the first round every pay
would be its own day and it would be
amazing wait a minute there may be some
offensive linemen out of Michigan State
who gets his own day I think that might
be a little overkill Ross probably but
it's better than whatever else we're
gonna be talking about then we'll see
how long in the second round goes
through but can you imagine that
the draft one pick first round every day
gets his own day and then their whole
day we talked about the Bengal it's like
bangles day on the Dan Patrick show then
it'll be Giants day on the Death Adder
show be honest um tweet it out I'm
interested to see what kind of response
you get great to talk to you again Ross
thanks for joining us All Right see you
guys stay healthy and safe that's Ross
Tucker former NFL player host to the
Ross Tucker podcast